我们现在先看到
尾盘有在资金做进场进驻的
记忆体族群了
2408的南亚科
我们记忆体的指标场
其实今天公道亮灯长庭
它还蛮强的
它是记忆体的指标
已经领先占回了所有均线
所以如果这个礼拜搭配说
国际大厂Sandix 威腾
要来公布财报
还有华邦店跟威刚也会有法说会
记忆体你怎么看呢
现在还能做卡位吗
好像是威刚
现在看起来是有点被上方均线压着
那这边你会怎么观察
其实这档股票
你们前两天有问我
我就说它季线是往上的
大家请记一下
你的口诀一定要记的
不要记一天就忘了
我们是不是跟各位讲过
说季线往上
就算跌破季线
它还是会重新站上季线之上
这叫葛兰币八大八折
然后KT指标在低档
我们看一下2408的南亚哥
然后我们前两天也跟各位讲
我说它的借券高达了8万多张
这根本就欲小不易
包含你看一下这个华邦店也是一样
我说华邦店的借券有16万张
总之只有12万张
它也会朝季线卖了
所以这种技术分析其实已经
我们太多案例可以跟各位讲了
除了这个以外你看一下伪创
伪创我们当时跟各位讲说
在7月22号那一天
它是用跳空的方式站上了季线
結果你看看今天的尾創
你看一下3231的尾創
马上又要创新高了
所以各位你请记
记线是生命线
一旦它跌破了
重新站上去
那威力有多大
我们再来看一下飞捷
我前天跟各位报告的时候
还被空单K
你看看昨天尝试
要来攻记线
今天完完全全的站上记线
你看6206的非解
所以同样的这种例子
有没有有啊
最近MCU都在涨价
那我昨天跟各位也报告了一档股票
你看一下松岸
我没有让你买了
他现在今天也是碰到季线
那会不会跟
你们到时候看到的
你刚刚讲到的南亚科一样
跟伟创一样
跟非解一样
我们就等着来看吧
因为他也是
季限是往上的
那今天刚好碰到季限
那如果他有办法跟菲捷一样
伪装一样
或者刚刚子金强
南亚科一样的话
他不会只有在这里而已
你们就慢慢看下去吧
因为我觉得这个盘
我必须重申一件事情
有一点点我有点生气
为什么
因为昨天的美国股市
导播可以让我们把几张图表
给各位看一下
第一张
美国的道琼昨天创了收盘历史新高
昨天的S&P收盘创了历史次高
昨天的纳斯达克
已经来到了下降压力线
来到了季线
可是我们今天就眼睁睁的看到一档股票
那一档股票是外资最看好的
他就拼命在压它为什么压它就是因为昨天我们明明看到昨天的美股表現那麼好為什麼期貨空單多了7500 23口你為了期貨做空而空
報告寫多 你對不起我們的國民
真的 我必須這樣講
因為台積電 各位想想看 前天最早站上季限的是台積電
沒有理由這兩天 美股那麼好的情況下
台積電反而要來跌破季線
你覺得如果不是空單在
外資的空單在作稅的話
台股會這樣嗎
你們覺得公平嗎
我們前幾天還在呼喊說
被動元件因為有很多股票跌太多了
所以不應該關緊閉關那麼久
結果昨天有一位立委一出來講完以後
那個政策就改了
現在剩下最後一個就是
我希望外资能够言行一致
不要说一套做一套
这样对台股伤害太大了
我是讲真心话了
因为我也要替股民发声
我们之前也跟各位讲说
被动元件不跌了以后
台股就要反弹
的确也反弹了
所以各位观众朋友们
这个行情不用担心
那陀老师你看被动元件呢
因为刚刚看到尾盘有在拉的
包括了3624的光洁
被动元件的小兵
其实目前有这个大单做超进涨幅
也是扩大超过5%
今天大家都在看的是2492的华星科
被动员间的二哥出关
不过还蛮震荡洗刷的
那包括2327的国聚
也是往上到时日线之后
开始出现了有一点点的压力
那今天的量也是比较明显的放大
那被动员间你怎么看呢
国聚有机会至少先谈到季线吗
应该这样讲
我们上次有跟各位说过
国聚的缺口应该会补
我覺得以我學的技術分析來講
國際現在越線是往下
但是它是左下右上
所以它第一個目標會先來越線
那因為它現在季線還是往上
所以它加油
為什麼
因為現在季線往上
你如果不趕快往季線靠的話
季線它的位置
現在大概在5月初那位置
所以它還有辦法一直維持往上
你等到開始它扣底比較高的時候
會往下壓的時候
就會比較慢一點
所以我是建議國劇要繼續往上衝
大盤還有機會
你們辛苦了那麼久
就等國劇休息的時候
被動員才會休息
不用怕 真的
而且我們昨天也講了
華新科今天雖然
我們看他沒有辦法鎖到漲停板
但是你仔細看一下
華新科是不是出現的背禮
倒不可以把底下放KD指標
它是不是股价上低
二次黄金加差
往上位置低檔背禮
那低檔背禮就会上
它今天是碰到了半年线
那我觉得像这股票
应该是会先往月线靠拢了
那下一步才会看季线
因为我觉得他们太辛苦了
辛苦已久了
那未来都有机会
反而我今天要跟各位讲
我们都没有留意到一个消息
涨价居然涨了三成了
一个礼拜涨了三成最近你知道什么样的题材可以一個禮拜漲三成大家都沒注意到其實今天應該要反映的應該是華碩、維新記者的股票
為什麼
因為從7月底到現在不到一個禮拜的時間
全球最大的電子產品批發零售商
深圳的華強北市場
顯卡的價格漲了三成
現在是一天一個價錢
都一路往上飆
最搶手的
回答的RTS5060
為例
前幾天的報價是
2700人民幣
已經上漲到
3100了
前幾天在2300而已
一個禮拜前是2300
現在已經到3100了
漲了800塊錢人民幣
3100塊人民幣
已經漲了3100
前一個禮拜才2300人民幣而已
那更高階的RTS5080系列的
已經超過1.1萬人民幣了
比7月份的時候多了1700塊
這個是台灣才要注意到的
一個禮拜漲三成的股票
我不知道今天有其他分析師講
你這個如果說大家不注意的話
你又錯過了一些大題材
所以今天本來應該長的就是華碩微星幾家
但是
誰會最受惠的
我跟各位講
大陸顯卡的龍頭是誰
七彩虹
這家公司
那七彩虹有轉投資誰
在台灣
只有一家
你聽清楚喔
我只講一次喔
2425的陳啟
所以我才看出為什麼陳啟最近的
為什麼會最近的業績那麼好
他第一季就賺了0.62
結果第二季竟然計算89.7%
也就是將近計算了快九成
然后他的最近也是一堆人
准备要再借券
又要再空他
没关系
我讲说你们要空的人你们空
你们空完以后就跟菲姐一样
就跟韦创一样
就跟松翰一样
我只想跟各位讲
來我給各位看一張圖形
導播你可不可以附一張
陳其我附過去的圖
你們要是懂得技術分析的
你就知道為什麼
當顯卡
對
這個打了26年的大底
上次高點62塊錢
你們如果常看我的節目
我只有一個口號
量價不會同時到頂
報告完畢
我不多講了
你反正我就跟你講
在中國大陸的顯卡
已经一个礼拜涨了三成
台湾如果一点反应都没有
我们也出了一点小问题了
那我就跟各位讲
你们要特别留意
华硕 微信还有技嘉
但是中国大陆的龙头显卡
最第一名的就是七彩虹
七彩虹有转投资的
就是台湾的2425的城市
大家看得办就好了
谢谢
好 那图老师
我们回过头来讲
刚刚的这个PCB上游呢因為這個禮拜其實包括明天日東訪的財報要來開獎禮拜五還有三井金屬其實今天看到PCB上游包括了波纖 包括了銅波
都有出現反攻的氣勢
像是富橋跟德宏
是鎖上亮燈暫停的
好 那我想問了
像是8358的京址
今天看起來是往上
來挑戰時日線
有壓力 不過量
有明顯的放大
那因為它跟這個
三井金屬連動會比較高
在这边你怎么看呢
会有机会展开反弹波吗
那1303的南亚
是前一波大家非常喜欢的
这个上游的波纤材料股
但是他这一波其实算蛮强势的
股价都维持在季线上
今天网上挑战月线
看起来有压
最近土阳一直对坐
那这边你觉得网上的空间有多少
我先回答一下这个京剧
京剧它是已经跌破连线
那这一波反弹先看到半年线就好了
你们自己去看
大概400块附近
你毕竟来讲的话
我说过了
他这一波来讲
他真的是因为跌破颈线以后才下跌的
所以你各位以后要留意到
他当时的颈线是在6月11号的510
然后上涨到758
跌破了510以后
就开始1比1的往下
做一个1比1的对等修正
那这种修正波来讲的话
现在因为KT指标在低档
有机会反弹到半年
先各位记一下就好
我为什么后来没有提金居
因为58块钱就涨太多了
至于你刚刚讲的南亚
有趣的
前天你们叫我写一份报导
说哪一些是融资减少的
迹象会上涨的
我就是写南亚
结果南亚开始就连续三天上涨
KT指标也是往低档出现黄金交叉
南亚这波强是强在
投信在买
外资跟他对坐
但是我觉得南亚应该没有走完
因为毕竟来讲的话
虽然他昨天融资大增
可是他昨天的借券也跟着增加
我觉得他有机会来挑战一次月线
大家把他祭牢就好了
谢谢
好那图老师
短短的时间帮我们看一下
五三四七的世界
因为世界先进
今天下午也是要来召开法说会
但是今天早上的股价
是有一点落落的
现在尾盘反而是翻红
那你觉得呢
它可以复制像是最近啊
光宝科星星
他们法说会之后会有行情吗
我觉得跟台积电有联动关系
就这样
因为这几天台积电比较弱嘛
那它现在季限是开始下弯了
所以我就讲说有些股票
真的要赶快重新能够站上
某一个重要的均线之上
因为现在毕竟
它跟台积电不一样
世界先进的季限是下弯了
所以你如果手上有的
这波反弹到季线的时候
我会建议各位先解码一趟
等拉回来的时候
我们再如果有买点的时候
我再跟各位做报告
因为我要就线论线
现在世界先进的季线是下完的
这是比较不好的地方
跟其他的股票有点不一样
但是我还是鼓励各位
我们没有那么糟糕的行情
就是希望外资能够原形一致
谢谢
好 谢谢兔老师